chris godwin do to become a free agent
here he is talking about his next
contract with our good friend pat mcafee
yesterday i think i'm
in the same boat as like a lot of
players you know like you want to get
you know some long-term security you
know you you want the team to
to commit to you as well um and so like
i
i think uh an extension would be ideal
but at the end of the day
you know if the franchise is what
happens then like that's what i gotta do
you know what i mean and then and then
we'll revisit later but
um you know i want to i want to be in
tampa but at the end of the day i want
to get paid
too yeah look you want to be in tampa
you want to get paid he also said
i'm not going to do something crazy and
and you know take a little more money
and go be unhappy somewhere well what's
the break-even point what is it is it a
million a year
right is it two million a year what you
know this is your opportunity to make
money that will take care of you
and your family years into the future
do you give up and that every every
guy's gonna make this decision for
himself
but what is the point where you say
okay i'm gonna say no
to that offer and i'm going to stay here
in this vague hope that somehow we can
thread the needle again because it's
it's easy to think
when you just have won the super bowl
yeah we can do it again well
it's not easy to do it and it can go
wrong
at any given moment and an injury
changes everything i mean
we talked about this last year with the
49ers to get back to the point where
they're up by
by 10 points with seven minutes left in
the super bowl
that the easy part is finishing the job
the hard part's getting to that point
and and what what happens week two
enough injuries to derail the season so
i just think that when you start talking
about compromising the financial
security of your family into the future
because of a hope because of a wish
because of a roll of the dice
thinking you're you're just gonna have
the same drunken boat party
that you had a couple of weeks ago i i
tell you what for me the break-even
point
would be a hell of a lot lower than it
would be for others well uh because
there's no guarantee that that you're
gonna
you're gonna ever win a super bowl again
no matter who you're playing with no
you're right there's not that you know
but
you know okay i mean we'll put yourself
in his shoes what
what is the breaking point i mean again
you know all right we look at a guy like
him
he's probably gonna make somewhere
between 16 to 18 million dollars a year
right i mean that's about the market for
that kind of
wide receiver right now in the nfl i
think that's what he's going to command
so as as an as an ex-player
at least my my thought would be hey
you're on a great team
all of that yes if they can just be i
think
i think the like the sweet spot what
you're saying is like two million
dollars two million dollars a year
whoo i don't know if i can do that can
we get into the 1.5
1 million i know it's a ton of money
that's a ton of money
i'm not i know but it's also
you know he's gonna probably get 40
million guaranteed
or something like that too so are you
willing to sacrifice
okay like you're saying maybe four or
five million dollars
over the long term of the contract
for winning games and you're still going
to make a lot of money it's not going to
be that close it's not going to be that
close you don't think it'll be
he's he's not going to be splitting
hairs or circumcising mosquitoes as
jerry jones would like to say it's not
going to be
that close someone else is going to
offer him
something that the buccaneers won't even
begin to come
close to remotely matching
in any way shape or form signing bonus
guaranteed money whatever
it's it's not going to be close it's
going to be obvious when it's time to
make the offers unless they get
shaq barrett signed yeah before two
weeks from yesterday and then turn and
use the franchise tag on chris godwin
which still would give him a lot of
money for one year but it would prevent
him from getting that
that generational wealth payday that's
the
the way that the buccaneers would be in
the game if he hits the market he's gone
i think because it's not even going to
be close yeah well
they have money right they're in a
pretty good salary cap you know position
as far as what is it a little north of
28 million dollars as far as where they
are right now
they can probably find some ways to
create a little bit more cap space but
you're right the the
as we've talked about a lot the wide
receiver position is not one you look at
in tampa bay and go
oh my gosh if they don't have chris
godwin they're just they're depleted
they have nothing no they have wide
receivers growing on trees there right
now
they do they have wep gr two really good
tight ends i know gronk i expect him to
be back so i'm saying that you know as
if he's gonna come back
so you know again yeah it's not a huge
need for the football team
but he was homegrown they did pick him
he is a jason light guy
that always organizations always want to
keep
their guys who they drafted and
developed
uh because of course it looked good on
them but i think the shaquille barrett
situation is going to be the biggest you
know
wrench or curveball in all of this
because you're right i mean he's going
to get paid
somewhere in that 19 to 20 million a
year range if he does get a long-term
contract
let alone we'll see what happens with
the franchise and all that so
uh your your logic is correct i i think
more or not that was the way i would
feel too that
that some team's gonna come in and kind
of make an offer that tampa's not gonna
be able to compete with and they're
gonna go man we got too many
other neat or other guys we got to
resign and we're pretty good at wide
receiver we love you chris godwin but we
just can't match that offer
let's hear from the buccaneers as it
relates to chris godwin gm jason light
on peacock yesterday with rich eisen
here's what
light had to say about godwin
well he's proven over the years since
we've had him that he's a very reliable
guy
he's uh he makes plays he's a great
teammate
great in the locker room and he's
been just very very good for us uh we
don't want to uh
we don't want him to to leave the
organization for by any means so
i'll just kind of give you the standard
answer i know you don't know you don't
want to hear it but we're going to do
our best to make sure that chris is a
buccaneer for a long time
yeah look they're not going to come out
and say we don't want to keep him
they don't want to be blamed for him
leaving anytime someone chases money
somewhere else you want the fan base
to come to its own conclusions about
whether or not the guy should have left
you don't want him to be sympathetic on
the way out the door but also
that's that's what the individual player
has to do he is a business he is a
corporation of
one and he's the ceo and he's got to
make that decision about his family's
future and yes there are other factors
i don't want to make it all about money
but i'd be stunned if
he gets to the open market and the
offers that are out there
are are even remotely close to what the
buccaneers are able to do i think the
offers out there are going to be a lot
better now
this is the week where his agent would
begin finding out in indianapolis
apparently
that the teams are freaked out about
having remote tampering because the cell
phone device
yeah right record there's tracking you
can't do the face-to-face conversations
like you do in indianapolis where it's
really a free-for-all but he'll still
know he'll know
they have that two-day period he'll know
uh before he says yes or no to the
buccaneers whatever their best offer is
he'll have a chance to know
what what else is out there and i think
what else is out there is gonna be
something he can't say no to well
let's like two two things just real
quick like first off
what does antonio brown's situation mean
for chris godwin right i would think
they'd want to try to pretty much figure
that out before
because whoa okay wait somebody offers
antonio brown a little money and
who knows i mean i don't see this
happening but i'm just throwing this
stuff
out there all of a sudden he goes tom
brady
takes the contract to antonio brown and
says sign this that's what happened
well i mean that's what i imagined
happening but i guess they got to make
sure
they got him before you just let chris
godwin go out the door
uh so that that to me would be another
aspect of this because i don't think
they want to let both of those guys go
and then you know they're still not in
horrible shape with scottie miller
and the kid johnson they drafted out of
minnesota who played well in the
playoffs as you mentioned many times so
we'll see where this goes but i'm with
you i don't expect to see chris godwin
back with the tampa bay buccaneers next
year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports